[Müzik]
önce merak ettiğim bir soru var
ekranlar hayatımızın içinde son bir
yıldır iki saat boyunca kesintisiz ders
çalışan kitap okuyan veya çok yakın bir
arkadaşla sohbet eden telefona
bilgisayara tablet hiçbir şeye bakmadan
zaman geçirebilen kaç kişi var elinizi
kaldırabilir misiniz Evet güzel
vakitleriyiz ama Dünya böyle değil
Biz şu anda kara kutunun ekranın yüzüncü
yılındayız
1922 yılında ilk özel teşebbüs
britishing
BBC kuruldu ve 1927 itibariyle
krallığa bağlı bir şekilde sürdürdü
varlığını ve hala yayınlarını dünyada
sürdürülüyor dünyanın ilk özel
Televizyonu ilk özel organizasyonu
televizyonlar latince kökenli pasifi
izleyici
şeklinde ifade ediliyor televizyon
kelimesi ve televizyonlar belki
1980'lere kadar
karşısındaki kitleyi bir durağan nesne
olarak görüp bu nesnenin tepkilerini
kendisini yöneten bir varlığa dönüştü
ülkemizde ise bu Yeşilçam olarak
adlandırdığımız 1970'lerdeki Fulya ile
sinema ile ve özel televizyonların TRT
yaklaşımıyla varlığını sürdürdü bu 1976
Nereye Bakıyor Bu adamlar filminin
İçinden bir görsel Hatta film afişi de
bu Zeki Alasya ve Metin Akpınar'ın
zeka derse de rahmetli anıyorum bu
dizideki örnek Reklamcılık sektörünün
ilk yansımasını Yeşilçam'ın göbeğine ve
merkezini almıştır diyerekten
yükseklerine bağlıyorum hanımefendi
Biraz önce moderasyonda paylaştık günlük
hayatımız etkilerim ekran dediğimiz şey
günlük hayatımızı etkilerim tamamen
sosyolojik bir şey beraberinde ticari
bölgenize dönüştü şu anki dünyadaki tüm
ticari varlıktan yürüten şirketler
kurumlar Hatta Politikalar bile
kişilerin
kişiselleşmiş
beklentilerin ihtiyaçlarını ve
yönlendirmeler ona göre şekillenmeye
başladı Halide dünyadaki bütün var
nesnelerde dünyadaki bütün olaylarda
işin sonunda Daha doğrusu günün sonunda
maalesef paraya baktığı için de bizim
ekrandaki beklentimiz ekranların dönüşüm
ve de bu oranda şekillenmeye başladı
TV'ye biraz daha dönmek istiyorum Çünkü
ben bir TV kurucusuyum bunu ulusal ve
globalde yürütüyorum ve televizyondan
Meseleyi ele almak istiyorum
televizyonlar Afrika'da 4 saat
Türkiye'de 3 saat Güney Amerika'da 3
saat bir spikeri de bir buçuk saat gibi
belli izlenme oranlarına sahip bu
izlenmelere baktığımız zaman ülkenin
gelişmişlik düzeyiyle hepimizin bildiği
bir şeydir bu
ülkenin mevcut durumunun sosyolojik bir
endeksi vardır Afrika O yüzden Günde 4
saat 4.5 saatin üzerindedir televizyon
izleyicisi televizyonun varlığı belki
son bunu 10 yıl olarak ifade edebiliriz
ama esas hissettiğimiz devrime
başlattığımız tarih
pandemi dönemiydi pandemi de biz artık
televizyonun bir kara kutu olarak
değerlendirmeye başladık
televizyondaki
2027-2022 arasında bir değişim
baktığımız zaman da çok ciddi bir
televizyon
izlenmesinin düştüğünü televizyonun
sadece bir araç olarak yani bir izlenme
aracı olarak gördüğümüzü paylaşabiliriz
dünyada nereye gidiyoruz dünyada sosyal
medya dediğimiz mobiliteye gidiyoruz bu
mobili de güncel rakamları paylaşayım
Yaklaşık 5 milyar kullanıcı var
dünyada bu kullanıcıların %90'a yakını
mobilden
internete bağlanıyor 5 milyar kullanıcı
internete ulaşabilen kullanıcı bu
kullanıcının %90'ı mobilden ulaşımını
sağlıyor ve dünyadaki bu rakam artık
ciddi anlamda yükselişini
bütün Tabana yayarak yaş ortalaması
düşürmeye başlayarak sürdürüyor yani
Örneğin 18 yaşından sonra çocukları
telefon alırdık gibi değişik dizilerde
izlediğimiz olaylar bugün ise artık
herkesin elinde bir telefona dönüşmesine
neden oldu hala Onlara göre bir sektör
oluştu Çünkü ne kadar güvendiğini ortaya
koysanız da Her yaşın bir sektörü Her
yaşın bir karşılığında onun satın alma
ilimlerini etkileyen bir yapıya dönüştü
yine dünya örneklerinde sosyal medyaya
baktığımız zaman bunun ekran olarak
bütün Türk eli almak istedim Çünkü
televizyon dediğimiz Kara Kutu bir
izleyici kutusuna Mobile'de dediğimiz
kavram ise internete ulaşabildiği ve
burada en uygun ve rahat Aracımızın
telefon olduğunu gördük bu telefona
baktığımız zaman da
dünyadaki Yaklaşık 5 milyar kişinin
sosyal medyadaki özellikle
gün içinde geçen zamanda bir şekilde
eşleştirmeye başladık
Şimdi burada
enteresan bir sonuç ortaya çıktı çünkü
net olarak şunu söyleyebilirim dünyada 5
milyar rakamını hep paylaşıyorum bir
milyar net kullanıcıların
sosyal medyadaki
eşlemesini ifade edebilirim Şöyle ki
önceki zamanlarda Biz dizilerimizi
filmlerimizi veya haberlerimizi
televizyonu alırken şu anda bütün bu
beklentilerimiz ihtiyaçlarımızı
sosyal platformlardaki
buradaki araçlardan almaya başladık bu
araçlarda kendi içinde muazzam bir
rekabete girdi buraya rekabetin Özünde
işi en küçük noktaya taşıdığımız zaman
ise kişiselleştirilmiş özelliklerin en
iyi kullanan araçlar en güçlü araçlara
dönüştü Örneğin
TikTok hayatımızın
şu anda merkezinde birçoğumuz tiktok'a
karşı biraz ara ve biraz alt ve ortak
kültür grubundaki insanların kullandığı
oradaki müziklere veya videolara
baktığımız zaman bizi yansıtmadığını
düşünüyoruz Ben de Aynı fikirdeyim ancak
tiktok'tan konuyu ele almak istersem
Türkiye'de bu rakam
son çok güncel bir rakam 40 milyon
TikTok kullanıcısı var ve TikTok
kullanıcılarımızı ortalaması Günde 4
saat
şimdi telefonlarınızı baktığınız zaman 6
saat 7 saat 8 saat gibi sayıları ekran
kullanımlarınızı görüyorsunuz
Instagram'ın günde 3 saat vakit
geçirdiğimizi rakamlarla söyleyebiliriz
ama
TikTok sadece son 3 ayda 90 milyon yeni
üye kattı 1 milyara yakın kullanıcıya da
anlık ulaşabiliyor ve burada Bizim
baktığımız zaman orada kendimiz ait
hissetmediğimiz O topluluk adına Öyle
kişiselleştirdi ki uygulamadaki
beklentilerimizi sizin 15 saniyede
sürekli yukarı doğru kaydırdığınız
farklı videoya geçtiğinizde Arka
plandaki algoritması bizim Esasen
zihnimizin arka planındaki beklentileri
önümüze koyuyorum
beğendiklerimizin ben ve ceketlerimizi
önümüze koyuyor ve birçoğumuz sabah
okula giderken işe giderken akşam
uyumadan önce Sabah uyandığımızda
yataktan çıkmadan biraz daha zaman
geçireyim dediğimizde
Eğer Instagram'a ve tiktok'a
yakalanmışsak minimum 15-20 dakikamızı
yiyor Çünkü Onun içinden çıkarmıyor bizi
Algoritma sizi oraya hapsediyor Burada
da
o
paylaşımların geri planda da e-ticaret
siteleri veya ticari tüm kuruluşlarda
Burayı çok yoğun bir şekilde kullanmaya
başladı buna baktığımız zaman YouTube
Instagram Facebook TikTok Twitter gibi
ekrandaki
tablo sonra 6 ay önce paylaşılmış bir
tablo tiktok'un son 3 aydaki atağını
koymadan bir rakamlar eşleştiriyoruz
burada e-ticarette Satın aldığımız her
şey Bununla birlikte günlük satın almak
istediklerim bizim Büyük bir kısmı veya
aldığımız haber kaynakları
izlediklerimiz izlediklerimizin kısa
versiyonları bunların hayatımıza
yansıması sosyal olarak bizi
etkilemesinin tamamı aynı zamanda ticari
bir ürün ticari bir ürün olması
nedeniyle dedi ekran dediğimiz Kara Kutu
televizyondan geldi bugün ise mobilde
bizi bir şeye yönlendiriyor
ilk söylemiş olduğum televizyondaki
pasif izleyici bugün aktif olarak
yönlendirici diye dönüştü Ama bu Biz son
noktaya geldiğim Biz olduğu söyleyemeyiz
Çünkü daha ileri gideceğim Biz başka
şeyler de var otomobillerden günlük
yaşamını birçok nokta nokta ekranlar
bizi artık kek edecek bizi yönlendirecek
veya
paylaşımlarımız isteklerimizi farklı bir
noktaya taşıyacak ekran dediğimiz ya
baktığımız o küçük alan Aslında bizim
yönlendirildiğimiz olduğumuz bir yer
haliyle
Türkiye'de
ve dünyada artık buna önüne geçmeniz
mümkün değil Somut bir Türkiye'nin
mevcut durumundan bir örnek vereyim size
son Yaklaşık 4 yıldır hiçbir televizyon
yeni lisans almadı
alamıyor Çünkü RTÜK yeni lisans sonra
vermiyorum Radyo Televizyon Üst Kurulu
ama
Türkiye'de 350 televizyonda ya satın
almalı ya da farklı şekillerde
yayınlanıyor Fox TV bundan 3-4 yıl önce
kurulduğunu tekeri tek
haberi almıştı veya tv100 Balıkesirli
bir televizyonu almıştı sonra yayınlara
çıkmışlardı yeni bir televizyon lisansı
alamıyorsunuz Rusya'da yeni bir
televizyon lisansı alamıyorsunuz
Fransa'da alamıyorsunuz Hatta Fransa'da
televizyon
sahipleri el değiştirdi ve o Fransa'daki
seçimlerde
sağ taraftaki
politikacılar desteklediği için
ciddi bir soruşturma süreci başlatıldı
bunun niye örneklendiriyorum Politik bir
örnek değil aslında bu bizim önceden güç
olarak ele aldığımız politikayı
belirleyen insanların hayata bakışlarını
ve duruşlarını belirleyen televizyonlar
Bugün o küçük alanda kendisin hala
korumaya devam etse de mobilde bizim
haber almamızı engelleyen hiçbir şey yok
İran'da hiçbir televizyonda yasak Çünkü
İran'daki kadınların Özgür dayanışmasını
izlemezsiniz Ama tüm dünya bunu izledi
Ukrayna Rusya savaşında ki yaşananları
Ukrayna'nın TV erişimini yetersiz
nedeniyle izleyemezsiniz ama bunu tüm
dünya
Ukrayna'daki bu savaşı izledim bu belki
faydalı veya toplumumuzun sosyolojik bir
örneği ama diğer tarafta da
hayatınızda
sadece telefonla 15 saniyeye giden
insanların
milyar
milyonlarca dolarlık milyar TL'lik
bütçeleri yönetebildiğini gördünüz
arkadaşımız hepimiz sanıyoruz tiktok'un
en çok takip edilen profili 150 milyon
kişi
İnstagramda da 80 milyon takipçisi var
sadece 15 saniye hiç konuşmadan
izlemiş olduğu tiktok'taki videoları
absürttüğünü ortaya koyarak kendisi
farklı bir açılım getirdi bugün
işçi olarak
tırnak içinde mülteci olarak çalıştığı
İtalya'da vatandaş oldu ve bunun için
hiçbir izin almasına gerek kalmadı
hiçbirisi başvuru yapmasına gerek
kalmadı
televizyona çıkma kapısının olmak gibi
derdi de olmadı mobilete bizim o
beklediklerimizi farklı Nokia taşıdı
sonra da hayalini kurdu bir markanın da
marka yüzü oldu
şimdi toplamında paylaşmaya çalıştığım
ekranların ulaşılabildiği markaların
bizim Önümüze koydukların
beklediklerimin ve bu kahramanlarımızın
örneği budur Bu örnekle
1970'lerdeki
şu gördüğümüz örnek aslında bir fark yok
Hatta belki hatırlayanlar veya Bilenler
İçin söyleyeyim 100 numaralı adam diye
Kemal Sunal'ın çok güzel bir filmi
vardır
bir kahramanlık televizyon tarafından
keşfettidir ve o reklamlarla birlikte
keşfedilmesinin o toplumun Güven duyuyor
yani ismi reklamlarla kapağı kırılan
buzdolabının tanıtılmasına kadar her
yerdedir bugün ise aradan evlilik yıl
geçti tiktok'taki farklı bir ikisi de
farklı bir Tekstil markasının yüzü oldu
haliyle ekranlar dediğimiz şey işin
özetinde
toplumun belirli kitlelerde varlığını
ortaya koymak Peki ben niye buradayım
ben
bu hikayeyi önce dünyada Nereye
gittiğimizi görmek adına paylaşmak
istedim Fakat bu konuşmayı acizani
yapıyor olmamın farklı misyonun bir
sonucu 2014 yılın lisans mezunuyum sonra
master'ımı tamamladım ve Ziraat
Fakültesi kökenli birisiyim Türkiye'de
tarım televizyonları 2009 yılında
kurulmuş
dünyadaki 2008 yılında kurulmuş 2019
yılında da ben farklı iş ortaklarımızla
birlikte şu anda Türkiye'de ve dünyanın
birçok ülkesinde yayın yapan agry isimli
bir televizyonun kurucusuyum aynı
zamanda yöneticisi olarak hayatımı
ticaretimiz sürdürüyorum agry TV
bereketli coğrafyamızın Kadim toprakları
sonra 50 yılda hem kendi topraklarında
doğayı gezegeni koruyacak şekilde
hayatını kazanmaları gerekiyor fakat
meslek itibari araştırmasında
çiftçilerimiz ilk 100 sırada bile değil
dünyada da böyle köydeki gördüğümüz
insanlar çiftçilik yapıyor
Biz agro TV'de
bu örnekten yola çıkarak Türkiye
vazelin'i kurduk Özbekistan Moldova
Romanya Bulgaristan gibi ülkelerin
tamamında iş ortaklığı yapıyoruz ve 15
ülkeye ulaşıyoruz Biz dünyadaki 550
milyon çiftçiye ulaşıyoruz 550 milyon
çiftçide ekranımızdan şunu paylaşıyoruz
biz
dünyanın ödülebilirliği için ekranımızı
Business bir şekilde faydalı bir araca
dönüştürmek istiyoruz ticari olarak da
tiktok'u instagramı YouTube'da
Gördüğümüz her şeyi Biz bunu tarımda
yapmak istiyoruz tarımda ortaya koymak
istiyoruz Çünkü dünyanın bizden sonraki
nesillerimize kalması gerektiğini
düşünüyoruz Haliyle benim kendi
mücadelemdi Temsil ettiğimizin Kurumu ve
oradaki
tüm irade gösteren arkadaşlarımızla
birlikte dünyada gıda gerçeğini
sürdürülebilirlik gerçeğini ortaya
koymaktır Bizim Hikayemiz Bu yüzden
Türkiye'de başlayan işi Azerbaycan'a
kurduk Pazartesi günü Fransa'ya
gidiyorum Fransa'daki TV agre ile Paris
Merkezi Avrupa popisini sonraki süreçte
de 500 milyon kişinin yaşadığı Afrika'da
tarım için gıda için Yayıncılık
faaliyetlerini sürdüreceğiz Bizim
Hikayemiz bu Biz ekranların hepimizin
çok etkilediğini ekran dediğimiz şeyin
TikTok ve Instagram'dan ibaret olduğunu
düşünüyoruz veya biliyoruz ama
sosyal bir farkındalığımız olacaksa bu
sosyal motivasyonumuzu kendi işimize
başka bir şeye dönüştürmeliyiz bugünkü
Kadim topraklarımız bizim değil
geleceğimizi taşıyacağımız Aslında
bugünün Biz varlığının bekçileri
olduğumuzu ifade ediyoruz Ben de acizane
hem bunu sürdürmek hem de bu
varlığımızın devamlılığı için de ekran
kavramını televizyon kavramını son 100
yılında 100 yıllık birikimle dönüşeceği
yeri hepimiz biliyoruz Ancak faydalı bir
şeye dönüşmesi noktasında da bir süreç
yönetiyoruz umarım gelecek dünya
bıraktığımız gibi olmaz yaşamlar
Sürdürülebilir tarımla sağlıklı gıdaya
erişimle pandemi gibi gerçeği tekrar
yaşamadan varlığımızı sürdürebilmemizi
sağlar teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]